[Music]
what is
the aspect of the pi data community that
attracts you the most
it's like a big family this is what i
liked it i liked when i went there
i felt like it's an amazing
atmosphere everyone is was friendly and
helpful
no one was like holding back um
information or data
in fact everyone was like excited to
share with you and talk to you about
um their tools and their projects and
they would talk to you also about like
how can you resolve their problems and
how can you
um overcome any obstacles you might find
i met
a lot of interesting people there and uh
i'm still in contact with some of them
so i understand one of your colleagues
that mosin is going to be presenting at
pi data global would you like to tell us
a little bit about what they'll be
speaking on
um we're going to talk about um
one of the libraries we're working on
internally which is name matching
it's about how arabic names are written
in english
or english names are written in arabic
it's a very interesting talk
because this is uh it wasn't it's not
available anywhere else in the world
and the way that the guys developed it
in um
at muzan it's it's very interesting the
way they
uh um came up with an algorithm
and uh um and text analysis part there's
a lot of nlp
work in there that can enable the
us to change so you know that when you
when you translate names it's very hard
so the way you write
the name in english can be can be in
different ways for one name in arabic
um so that that that's uh one of the
things that actually
um empowered mozun to develop more
around data and have more
uh solutions around data
[Music]
you